[موسيقى]
إنها اللحظة المحمومة التي لاحظ فيها الضباط
ما كان على وشك أن يحدث
اصطدام قطار شحن
بطراد شرطة بلاتفيل المتوقفة على
سكة قطار على طول الطريق السريع 85 وطريق كاونتي
36.
أنا فقط في السيارة التي اصطدم
بها القطار المغلق بالداخل  احتجز طراد الشرطة
ريوس غونزاليس
لحادث غضب مزعوم على الطريق في وقت سابق
من الليل
حوالي دقيقة وتسع ثوان بعد
وضع ريوس جونزاليس في الجزء الخلفي
من طراد الشرطة المقيّد بالأصفاد
، تم سماع بوق القطار لأول مرة
من مسافة بعيدة.  على كاميرا الجسد هذه
بعد حوالي سبع ثوانٍ ، يسجل
بوق آخر
هذه المرة بصوت أعلى ولكن لا يزال هناك أي رد فعل
من الشرطة خلال الثواني الثماني التالية
حتى يتم سماع المزيد من الأبواق قبل أن
يدرك هذان الضابطان أن ريوس غونزاليس في
خطر
يا إلهي
[الموسيقى]
إنها مستيقظة و  مدركة وقادرة على
إجراء محادثة ولكنها لا تزال في المستشفى
وفقًا لمحاميها بول ويلكينسون
، فقد أصيبت بكسر في ذراعها بعد أن
خضعت لعملية جراحية في المستشفى.
في الضلوع المكسورة كسر في عظمة القص أو
ترك إصابات في الساق
للخلف وتوجيه العديد من الأسئلة يبقى
أكبر سبب أوقف الضابط
الطراد على المسارات لماذا يقدمها
ذلك ثم وضع ريوس غونزاليس في ذلك
الطراد ولماذا استغرق الأمر ثوان حرجة
للإشعار  القطار يقترب أكثر من
إنذار
أنه يمكنك سماع القطار
قادمًا وهو في الليل والقطار
به أضواء أيضًا حتى تتمكن من سماع
ورؤية القطار القادم. يقول ويلكنسون إن ريو
غونزاليس سمعت ورأت ذلك القطار قادمًا
جيدًا قبل أن يفعله الضباط  في محاولة
لجذب انتباه الجميع ولكن على عكس
هؤلاء الضباط ، لم يكن بإمكانها فعل أي شيء
لإنقاذ نفسها
[موسيقى]